good afternoon my name is adrian dicks
i'm bc's minister of health to my right
is dr bonnie henry bc's provincial
health officer
zarakova 19 briefing for british
columbia our update for british columbia
for wednesday february the 23rd
we're honored to be here on the
territory of the le cuangon speaking
people of the sangees and the esquimalt
first nations and with that it's my
honor to introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
and thank you for joining us for this
week's covet 19 pandemic update
last week
we announced as i'm sure many people
know the easing of some of the orders
and restrictions that had been in place
particularly the the ones that have been
in place over the last
month and a bit as we learned more about
omacron and we continue to see uh that
things are leveling off although we are
still of course
having challenges in some areas of the
province our progress though remains on
track and we are continuing to see this
steady decline and these are positive
and encouraging trends and as you know
we have committed to reviewing things in
the next few weeks with the
with the goal of
removing additional measures as soon as
we possibly can
another important and positive note
today uh our managing our management
strategy as you know is supported by a
number of vaccine and treatment options
some of which have become new and we
anticipated that
there will be new both vaccine and
treatment options to come in the weeks
and months ahead however we do know that
last week health canada approved for use
a new
class of vaccinations one called novofax
this is
will be available in bc in the next few
weeks
we don't have a that has not yet arrived
but we are expecting to have it in
british columbia in the next week to 10
days
and i think this is really good news
this is an important new
different class of vaccinations it is
what we call as a protein subunit
vaccine it's another option for people
who require immunization who've not yet
been vaccinated and need it for work or
for people who are healthcare workers
for example for people who have had a
reaction to an mrna vaccine
this is a
perfectly good and valid option to to
make up those doses that you need to get
full protection
this is a an interesting vaccine it's
one we've been watching for some time
and it's it's
no human derived materials we're
involved in its development it uses an
insect cell line
which is really cool a moth cell line
and it also has an adjuvant that's made
out of soap bark tree extract so it is a
plant-based as well in part of it and
what it does how it's different from the
mrna vaccines they give the genetic code
for this the spike protein of the sars
coronavirus uh two
uh virus and your body then generates
those proteins in this case the proteins
are
the virus
baculovirus is used and it's generates
proteins that are then purified from
these moth cells and the proteins are
put together with this matrix made out
of
the soap bark tree extract and so you're
given the proteins directly and those
stimulate your own immune system to
develop antibodies
both antibodies and cell mediated
immunity against those proteins so this
is a more traditional type of vaccine we
have a number of other vaccines that use
similar
protein subunit technology including
some of the influenza vaccines hepatitis
b and zoster so
it's a tried and true uh methodology of
making vaccines and we know the immune
system responds well the data that we've
seen that health canada has proved show
it's uh very uh efficacious as well so
the effect the efficacy and the trials
is upwards of ninety percent of protect
preventing infection so this is great
news
and another really important thing it's
a fridge stable vaccine so we don't have
all of those issues that we had in terms
of uh
needing to have ultra low temperature
freezers etc
we will like the one dose johnson
johnson the viral vector vaccines it
will be available primarily through
pharmacies and some of our
our health authority clinics but if you
are interested in the nova fax vaccine
the best thing you can do is call right
now our coveted line uh the cova 19
vaccine line so that's 1-833-838-2323
and tell the people that you're
interested in getting the novavax
vaccine what we'll do is make sure we
have your contact information and when
the vaccine is available your dose will
be reserved for you in either pharmacy
or clinic close to where you live and
you'll be able to get that as soon as it
comes in so i think this is fantastic
it's another really important tool that
we have now in our toolbox that's going
to get us through both this omicron wave
but is also going to get us through what
comes next because we know that the
importance of the protection that we get
from vaccination is one of those things
that has made sure that we can get
through this
for those who have not yet booked your
booster shot i strongly encourage you to
book your appointment at your local
pharmacy in particular as soon as
possible as more and more people have
been vaccinated our our demand in our
large
clinics is ramping down and so the coven
19 clinics will be focusing the health
authority clinics will continue to focus
on the five to 11 immunizations
particularly because we know there's
there's important things that we need to
have in those clinics to support
families and children but adults can get
any of our available vaccines at local
pharmacies
in addition to additional vaccine
options we also have as we talked about
about two weeks ago
an additional treatment called pax
levitt that is now available we have got
a little bit more supply in the province
in addition to cetrovamab which is a
monoclonal antibody and there are
additional monoclonal antibody
treatments that are
approved for use and are going to be
available in canada in the future
these are especially important for
people who are at high risk of having
severe illness if they
severe illness and hospitalization if
they get coveted and particularly it
includes people who are older
people who have immune compromising
conditions and for those people
we know you as clinically extremely
vulnerable you've got those notes we
made sure that you got your vaccines
early but we do know that some people
even with three doses of vaccine even
with a booster dose
don't have a strong and immune response
and so these treatments are available
now for you
they're also important for people who
are not yet fully vaccinated and people
especially if you're over 60 or you have
other underlying illnesses
so these are a positive step forward but
as we talked about as well like all
medications they're not suitable for
everyone in particular paxolavid has a
number of interactions with the number
of medications that people may be taking
so to receive the either of these
you have to have a positive cova test
and a pcr or rapid antigen test and we
are prioritizing people who may need
these treatments to be able to get pcr
tests
and the treatments need to be started
within the first few days the first five
days in particular of your symptom onset
so on today
we have had access through infectious
disease physicians in different parts of
the province and i want to thank them
for the work that they've been doing but
we are also now setting up a
self-screening tool that is now
available and and our call support
center so that people across the
province can determine if this is a
treatment that would be right for you
and how you can access it
so to request uh treatment and we'll
send the link around there'll be a
four-step self-screening tool that you
can go online and find out if this is
either of these are treatments that
might be uh suitable for you and a
virtual assessment service that will now
be available through the province's
covet 19 information center around the
province so we'll be sending out the
links to those information and posting
them on our covet 19 websites and on the
bccdc website
these are important to help prevent
severe illness
but it is also a reminder that the most
important thing we can do is preventing
getting sick in the first place and that
of course means vaccination
it is our most important tool
particularly for older people for people
who have
reasons that make them clinically
extremely vulnerable to covet we know
and we've presented these data that two
doses remains very very effective at
preventing severe illness even eight
months ten months later
and we know now from data from the bccdc
from data that's been collected as well
in quebec and other parts of the world
that that booster dose makes a
difference it makes a difference in
boosting that prevention for severe
illness and hospitalization but it also
prevents transmission and it's about
sixty percent seventy percent effective
of preventing any symptoms at all and in
quebec they didn't looked as well it's
about 80 percent effective if you get
that booster dose it reduces your risk
of needing to go to an emergency
department because of symptoms because
of covet
so we do now have good strong data that
tells us with omicron that getting that
booster dose is important it prevents
you from getting sick at all it prevents
transmission and it prevents illness
so please if you've not yet if you've
been invited it's been six months um go
out and get that booster shot and if you
have concerns because of the uh on a
reaction perhaps to your second dose of
the mrna vaccines it is an option to get
novavax as a booster dose
depending what other
vaccines you've had initially
if you've not yet had your first or
second dose even if you're particularly
if you're a young person 5 to 11 please
talk to your pediatrician talk to your
pharmacist about the importance of
protecting
young people from illness as well we
still have a lot of this virus that's
circulating and this protection is good
strong safe protection and long lasting
and will help us for what we're dealing
with now
but also as we're going through this
transition phase and into the future
testing of course continues to be part
of our ongoing efforts and last week it
was shared that we finally have received
quite a lot of the at-home tests that
are
available for people these are rapid
tests that can be used by people at home
and they'll be distributed they've
already started through school
throughout the province
and
the tests will
soon be able to
be
we're also be distributing them to
people
based on their risk which of course
means age and i'll leave it to the
minister to give details of that
but i want to just remind people that
these tests are
a tool that helps you determine what
activities you can do
if you have symptoms that's when they
are best used and i've talked about this
before they're a red light and not a
green light so if you have symptoms and
you want to know if there you need to
know if they're covet then these rapid
tests are a really great way of doing
that and then you need to isolate until
you're
five days or until you're better
if you don't have symptoms or sorry if
you have symptoms and you test negative
it doesn't mean that all of those other
measures that we have in place right now
you can ignore it means that you need to
continue taking uh taking care making
sure that you're staying away from
others until your symptoms resolve
as more tests arrive in bc we'll be able
to expand our availability to even more
people and i will refer people to the
bccdc and we'll put links again
on guidance and how they are best used
to support your decision making for you
and for your family
in the coming weeks and months
we are also transitioning to what will
be our sustainable covet 19 management
strategies we've talked about and we've
been focusing on effective response
recovery and then readiness for what
lies ahead this means we will be
continuing things like our whole genome
sequencing surveillance and i know
there's been a lot of concern about
potential variants
about variants like the ba 0.2 the
omicron variant that is
increasing in transmission in some
countries around the world like denmark
and the uk
we have seen that here in bc and more in
different parts of the province it is
increasing but slowly here in british
columbia we'll continue to monitor that
we've also been monitoring things like
the el the delta omicron variant that
has been causing a few clusters
particularly the uk and australia we've
not yet seen any of those
mixed variants here in bc but our whole
genome sequencing program is designed to
detect those and we will continue to
look for these
we will also continue to expand our
surveillance streams using such things
that we've done periodically like zero
surveys to help us understand how much
immunity is in the community we are in
the process process of expanding the
wastewater surveillance that has proven
to be so helpful as yet another marker
that helps us understand what's
happening
and continuing to monitor things like
the pcr test positivity rates geographic
rates of disease and outbreaks and
illness
each step of the way as we move through
this next few weeks we'll be making our
decisions about lifting restrictions
about lifting mandates and orders based
on what we are seeing here where we're
seeing transmission and the data that we
have about our pandemic here in british
columbia and as you know we are at a
different pace and a different place in
our pandemic than many other parts of
the world and the country it is
important to remember that while our
cases are coming down covet 19 is still
actively circulating and i know
many people who have children know that
that we're seeing it in young people in
schools associated with some schools and
we're also seeing it in in communities
around the province in different ways
we also have seen tragically that we
still are seeing people dying from covet
19. most of them are people who have
underlying illnesses people who are
older however in the last few days we've
had four people in their 40s who've died
from covet 19.
that's important it reminds us that
everybody has risk right now we still
have high levels of transmission and if
you don't have the protection that
vaccine gives you
there there is a possibility of having
more severe illness and ending up in
hospital so i encourage anybody who's
not yet taken that move to to think
about novovax as an option right now
keeping our covet safety basics are just
important today if not more so than they
were last week as we've started to get
back to many of those activities and
social activities that we've missed over
the last month or so so i ask that you
please be respectful of others as we go
through this transition
we can and should all go at our own pace
at our own comfort levels
we need to be make sure that we are
wearing masks where it's appropriate for
us keeping our distance from people
particularly if we have people in our
family in our community in our workplace
who are vulnerable to more severe
illness
it's about moving slowly and gradually
in the one-way direction only so that we
don't have to have
a turning back of the dial
this means all of us continuing as we've
been doing in bc to be accountable to
each other to manage our own risks and
equally important be mindful and
respectful of the risks of those around
us
this is our long-term sustainable
strategy that will get us through this
transition period and help us deal with
what comes next as omicron fades and as
we see what comes next in this pandemic
these are the things that will get us
through
and on today on pink shirt day
i remind us
that lifting each other up
is important and it is how we will get
through this pandemic together and
continue to remind us to do that and to
remind us to be kind with each other
thank you
uh thank you very much dr henry today
i'll provide an update on bc's rapid
test inventory
and updates on healthcare workers off
sick last week and surgical
postponements and we have a slide deck
which will be available to the public
members of the media after the
presentation
that describes
the rapid antigen test distribution
strategy and uh we'll go through that
now i'm going to get some help
the uh inventory summary first of all
we've been reporting this week to week
and this is as of february the 22nd 2022
or yesterday bc has received 22 million
242 902 tests
we've deployed 14 million 843 222 tests
and that leaves seven million three
hundred and ninety nine thousand six
hundred and eighty three tests in
inventory we're expecting approximately
and this depends um on our distribution
on our when we receive them from the
federal government approximately three
million tests per week in the coming
four weeks for 12 million tests
reminding you that about 558 000 of
these tests are not suitable for home
use and although those tests will be
continued to be used by public health
to support uh particularly
in dealing with clusters of cases so if
we go on to the next slide which is
which is not the last week but this is
brings us up to february 22nd you'll see
that over the last week married to last
week we distributed a further 4 million
4.83 million
tests around bc in the last week 3.3
million of them
went
to k-12 schools or post-secondary
institutions and another
another 418 000 were distributed to
other
population channels primarily long-term
care and assisted living and a number of
tests about 865 000 have been
pre-positioned for community tests
distribution by pharmacies and we'll get
to that later you'll see on this slide
if we go back to the slide
that we see the overall distribution of
tests which is uh 12 million 838 020
since december 13th 2 million prior to
that and that the largest number uh so
far have gone to education to long-term
care to health care workers and the kova
testing sites but they've also gone to
rural remote and indigenous communities
to child care facilities
and most recently to pharmacy
distributors so that's where the rapid
tests have gone
distribution
this week
we'll continue to
to focus in on those so all of those
priority areas that we've talked about
will continue to be replenished as tests
are used whether it be long-term care or
remote communities or others
we're now of course expanding that
strategy regarding rapid antigen tests
and
what we're going to do is make tests
availability uh
easier for people and get them into the
hands of more people for their use when
they're symptomatic and dr henry talked
about that in her presentation
the next slide
so here are the new uh approaches
uh no that's all right we got the new
approaches uh to to it because as you
can see the priorities have been the
priorities we laid out
over the last number of while you've
seen the distribution those priorities
as sufficient
numbers of rapid tests have come into
place
we're developing new approaches and
you're seeing that in evidence this last
week and this week
previously we focused on priority
high-risk populations last week we
announced additional distribution
through schools k-12 and post-secondary
with the important shift of tests now
being taken home for use at home by the
student and their families if they were
to become symptomatic as we announced
last week that was that's 5.9 million
tests going to go to that purpose
essentially five per student that
process has begun of course to happen
and you saw a very significant number of
those tests distributed last week this
week we're adding community distribution
channels through community pharmacy to
make more tests accessible to the full
population
so the next slide
what's the same what's the same is that
we're continuing that the focus
continues remains on using the test for
when an individual is symptomatic
focus remains on striving to have tests
available particularly for those who are
most at risk that is those who are
susceptible to severe illness and death
from covid19 those individuals where
testing is clinically indicated or a
positive result with impact treatment or
care individuals who live or work in
settings with others who are high risk
for severe illness
high risk individuals continue to be
encouraged to seek a pcr test if they
are systematic and what is new we're
increasing test availability through
existing channels of distribution and
we're creating new channels such as
pharmacies
increased test availability means more
members of the general public will be
able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness and take action to limit
transmission to their friends family and
work including those at higher risk
so
and so this is what we've done in the
last week as you see the distribution
update uh shows that that in the last
week we're seeing we've seen this
distribution of tests we'll move on i
spoke about that earlier
and so what's new is the pharmacy
distribution that pharmacies
will distribute a rapid antigen test
containing five tests through this
additional channel to interested
individuals there will be no cost to
citizens for these tests more than 865
000 have already been pre-positioned to
a pharmacy distributor from which
pharmacies can order and receive stocks
kits will start be being available for
pickup at select pharmacies as early as
friday and is expected that the number
of locations will grow rapidly with time
and supply
please check and there will be a website
at the bc pharmacy association for a
list of pharmacies that are dispensing
tests
how will it work well for starters we're
going to use the same approach we've
taken throughout the pandemic and
getting focus in on those who are most
at risk to severe outcomes from cloven
19 and that means in particular
those over 70. so that's where we're
going to start distribution will start
for those 70 and over who are amongst
the highest risk as we know and so in
the initial period if you're you'll need
to be 70 or over to get access to these
tests once distribution has started and
supply grows a broadening to younger
ages will essentially go down
the age ladder as we have previously
broadening to younger ages is expected
to happen quickly and will be
communicated by our government
covenanting website individuals will
present their bc services card at the
pharmacy and will be given their test
free up kit free of charge to ensure as
many people as possible have access
there will be a limit of one kit per
person within a 28-day period
you can pick up a kit for a family
member another person you must provide
their name date of birth and have their
bc services card with you
and so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to be starting for all those at
the beginning over 70 and then moving
down the age brackets this will assist
in distribution in particular assist
those who are most vulnerable to get
access to rapid tests so what do you do
if you have a positive test dr henry has
talked about that there's full
instructions on the bccdc website i
encourage you to go there
and there's four things new report your
test at reportcovedresults.bccdc
self-isolate manage your symptoms notify
your close contacts
and finally going forward as more tests
arrive and as supply and capacity allows
we'll be providing greater access to all
bc citizens increased test availability
means more members of the general public
will be able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness so what we've done from the
beginning as we laid out in our plan on
december 21st is prioritize prioritize
the people most at risk and the first
millions of tests as they arrive were
prioritized for that reason now we have
more tests and first last week out to
schools and post-secondary institutions
k-12 schools and post-secondary
institutions and starting the end of
this week through community pharmacies
to people in the community starting with
those over 70 and as they say as more
tests arrive we'll be able to lower
those age the age groups who are
eligible to get tests with respect to a
second issue today
the impact of sickness on health care
workers we saw a decrease in the number
of staff with short-term illness uh 14
579 during the week of february 14th to
20th that's down from the previous week
which reported fifteen thousand five
hundred and twenty four health care
workers off sick that's three thousand
one hundred and twenty seven in fraser
health two thousand eight hundred and
forty in interior health one thousand
1510 in northern health 1478
in the provincial health services
authority
2044 in vancouver coastal health
3018 in island health and 562 in
providence healthcare remember this is
off sick for all reasons
and it is continues to be higher than
than previous periods in previous
equivalent periods february and previous
years but it has significantly come down
as you know two weeks ago and three
weeks ago it was between 17
and 18 000 and now it's down under
15 000 to 14 579.
health authorities with respect to
surgeries report that 6070 surgeries
were completed from january 23rd to
january 29th
uh from february 13th to 19th health
authorities postponed 288 non-urgent
scheduled surgeries at six in fraser
health four in northern health 270 in
interior health six in island health two
in the provincial health services
authority no surgeries were postponed in
the vancouver coastal health authority
cumulative
cumulatively from september 5th
uh 2021 to february 19 2022 regional
surges of covet and factors including
severe weather patterns have caused
7925 surgical postponements as you can
see this was primarily and continues to
be primarily an issue in the interior
health authority our staff there is
working flat out to support patients we
are continuing to deliver urgent
urgent scheduled surgeries and emergent
surgeries in the interior health
authority and we'll be making efforts
continued efforts to support that health
authority as it deals with the impact of
the covet 19 pandemic on may 7 2020 we
made a surgical renewal commitment to
patients we said we'd do three things we
said we would deliver surgeries that
were postponed because of the pandemic
we said we would schedule and deliver
surgeries that were not scheduled
because of the pandemic and we said we
would change the way we deliver
surgeries to get more patients their
surgeries faster
as we've reported in weekly updates
since then despite what kova 19 and
severe weather have done to the
challenge of achieving achieving these
goals we have done what we said we would
do and we continue to deliver on our
commitment
as we reported last week patients whose
surgeries were postponed in this fifth
wave have started to get their calls to
rebook their surgeries
patients whose surgeries were postponed
in this fifth wave have started to
receive their surgeries
innovations to increase surgical
capacity were launched in every health
authority across our surgical sites
benefiting everyone in need of surgeries
we will complete the postponed surgeries
we will continue to increase surgeries
and we will improve access far beyond
what the pandemic has set us back
our commitment to change the way
surgeries are delivered in bc that's our
commitment and that is what we are doing
and that is what we are going to
continue to do
the patients in all health authorities
are getting calls to rebook their
surgeries is in large measure because of
the work we're all doing all of us are
doing to stop the current surge
and those calls will continue to occur
and will increase in direct proportion
to all the actions we continue to take
to stop covitt's spread our work makes
all the difference your work makes all
the difference and for that reason our
work is not done and with that we're
happy to take your questions
a reminder to media on the line please
press star one to enter the queue you
will be limited to one question and one
follow-up our first question today comes
from richard zusman global news
how will pharmacies this could be for
either dr henry or minister dix
how will pharmacies
ensure that the right people are getting
the tests if somebody shows up under the
age of 70. will they be told they can't
have a test
how quickly should those under the age
of 70 expect to have access i know in
the presentation you said soon is that
this week next week by the end of the
month what's what's the timeline uh in
that regard and how do you ensure those
that are symptomatic
are the ones that are actually getting
the tests as you've laid out the
presentation
well a couple of things and i'll start
and see if the minister has things to
add but one is we don't want symptomatic
people to go into a pharmacy and get a
test kit right now that's not if you're
symptomatic and you're in any of the
high risk groups or you need to have a
test because of your symptoms you can go
to the symptom screener get a pcr test
or go to one of the testing centers and
receive a testing kit there
these are for people to have at home to
use when they need to make a decision
about what to do when they have symptoms
in the future so we are prioritizing
because we know that there's a pent-up
demand out there and we finally have
enough that we can
distribute them out more broadly to
people but we want to make sure
that the access is is
that we prioritize access for people who
are more at risk and that's our seniors
and elders we know that we know they've
always been most at risk and that is for
them to have to use either for
themselves if they get symptoms
but importantly to be able to use as a
tool to screen people who are around
them if they need to so if you're coming
to visit or if there's somebody that's
coming into your center particularly
into your into your home
particularly if they're concerned about
symptoms um this is something that
people can use to help manage their own
risk around them
so yes we'll be starting and we we
intentionally started with people over
the age of 70 so that they would get
preferential access at the first we know
that there'll be a lot of
people who want them now and as we get
more and more available they'll be
available to everybody but we want to
make sure it's easy for those who are
most at risk to get them first and
that's going to happen starting friday
if we get the supplies that we're
expecting over the next four weeks and
then i fully expect it will be available
to everybody to pick up over the next
probably three to four weeks at the most
and so this is not going to help
determine what you do today if you're
feeling unwell today but it is something
that will help us for the future for the
next few weeks and months but really
importantly these are tools that we can
get used to using in certain situations
for helping manage self-manage our own
risk and the risk of our families and so
we know that a lot of younger families
will be getting the the test kits
through schools
many people are getting access through
their workplaces so we want to make sure
that with this first tranche that's
coming in we're
prioritizing it and making the easy for
elders and seniors to get access as well
and where it will be important is as we
move through this transition period now
and hopefully continue to see cases
decrease in communities
when we start to see sporadic increase
in cases of respiratory illness next
fall maybe or even before if that
happens
then people will have these tools at
home that they can use to help
self-manage their risk
did you want to add anything
so richard we laid out two sets of
priorities the first were students in
k-12 and post-secondary education and
those are even going out and will be
distributed to them that's
5.9 million tests
and so that
with
test packages of five is more than a
million people which is significant to
focus on that group of people as we
make the tests available to broader
public distribution we're starting with
people 70 and over so those are the ones
who would have access
in in the initial period to the test and
that those age groups will go down as
we've seen with other things for example
uh vaccination so you'll provide you go
you provide your uh your date of birth
and and uh your bc services card or your
health number and uh and get access to
the test to your package of tests so
you'll be able to have that that at home
it's a good way to distribute them and
ensures
i think a calm distribution that focuses
the tests initially on those most at
risk from covet 19. so it'll be
something that people will understand
well and of course all the tests will be
provided
free of charge to people in bc
richard do you have a follow up
is there any update i think probably for
you dr henry from last week
when you mentioned that the college
are investigating doctors who are
spreading misinformation is there any
update on whether how those
investigations are going or where we're
at with those concerns
and also we're working on a story
tonight of two firefighters who are
required to get vaccinated and they
produced uh fraudulent vaccine cards um
is this sort of thing acceptable and
what can the province do
to ensure that people are not producing
uh fake vaccine cars to their employers
so with regards to the first i have no
insight into
the college's processes that they have
to investigate
i did see something in the media that
at least one physician was had there was
something happening but i really can't
talk to that you'll have to
talk to the college
there's uh i have no way of knowing how
these things are progressing but i know
that they do have a process that has
gone through
in terms of
people providing fraudulent vaccine
information this is something we talked
a little bit about
a couple of months ago we do have ways
of determining if if a vaccine record is
a true record and we were following up
on a few
i think it was around a thousand that we
knew were fraudulent records and so that
is a process that the phsa or msbc
program has and if needed
when i know there was at one point some
people making profit off of fraudulent
vaccine records
that police would be involved i can't
speak obviously to these two individuals
but i will say there is a new option now
if people had concerns about the
vaccines if they had worries about
confidence in the effectiveness and the
value of the mrna vaccines
that they have other options now
including the nova vax vaccine that was
just approved for use so i would
encourage people
to get the protection that you need
especially if you're in an important
position like an emergency responder
like firefighters are did you want to
have that
next question comes from maria
weisgarber ctv
either i was curious with the
distribution of the free rapid test kits
now through schools for k-12 uh will the
gargle tests also still be made
available through schools i know those
were being offered as well for a while
for uh students who are symptomatic at
school
yeah so the gargles is a way of
collecting a less invasive way of
collecting
a sample for pcr tests and yes
absolutely we still have gargles
available for younger people also for uh
for adults who don't like having a swab
stuck up in their in their nose and
those are available uh i know
some of the schools are still
using those so the rapid tests serve a
different purpose so they are ones that
you can take home to help support those
decision makings when you if and when
you develop symptoms at home so slightly
different purpose they're they're more
thinking about how would we manage in
the future
but absolutely the gargle tests are
still available at all of the testing
centers and i know are are easily
accessible in some of the schools um
i know it's a little bit of a different
program in different parts of the
province but absolutely they are the pcr
tests
maria do you have a follow-up
uh yes i i was curious about the online
reporting i know that um uh the
provinces indicated if people get
positive results on the route the test
you know
they're asking if people would report uh
results uh online to this bccdc i'm
curious about the rate of uptake with
that uh if there have been many results
being reported and uh now that there's
going to be a wider distribution
is the province still
putting a lot of importance on people
self-reporting voluntarily
self-reporting if they get a positive
result
yeah so it's a bit of a challenge
it is one way of helping us understand
you know how many people are getting a
positive
test on the rapid test
but there are many many limitations and
that's one of the reasons why we have
we're not including it as a as a routine
surveillance stream because as you know
the the access to tests is changing and
it's only
only numerator data so we don't actually
know how many tests have been used at
any point in time so it doesn't give us
a sense of what proportion of people are
testing positive it does give us a
little bit of an idea from a different
in a different community for example uh
on who's testing
and who is testing positive of the
people that are testing so
it really is
limited information um and
it will be a potentially and useful tool
not so much right now when we still
don't have a lot of
you know as testing is in access to
testing is increasing to the rapid tests
but it can be something
where we can target
people being able to download that
information in a specific community i'm
thinking in the future if we start if we
get down to a nice low level of
transmission and then we see uh
respiratory uh illness going up in a
certain community we can target that
community and say hey if you're using
the rapid test please
let us know if you're positive and so it
is an important tool that we don't yet
know all of its
how it can be used we've been talking
with colleagues in the uk in particular
who've had
rapid tests in the community available
for quite a long period of time and and
do have a very similar
voluntary reporting online and it there
are limitations to that so
we're still trying to figure out where
it's most of value
next question comes from lisa eusta city
news
hi there i'm asking a question on behalf
of a colleague and regarding long coved
i'm wondering with omicron and the
faster incubation period we're hearing
from people who are finding that at two
and a half months they're they're
feeling like they're having long coveted
and and their doctor thinks they are but
they can't get into the clinics yet
because there's a three-month
um cutoff so i'm wondering is the
criteria at this point too narrow is it
going to change
um as i guess more people have become
infected and i'm wondering you know
where you're at with that and what what
you have to say on that so there's lots
of um there's actually some really good
information that's come out of a number
of other countries particularly the uk
who started following this through their
family physician clinics primary care
clinics
so yes by definition
one doesn't meet the criteria for a long
covet until 12 weeks from your infection
so that's a standard definition that
people are using around the world it
doesn't mean that people don't have
symptoms in that period of time
but many people they'll resolve within
uh 12 weeks so that's one of the the
sort of case definition cutoffs the
other thing that we're finding is
that
vaccination
if you get infected after being
vaccinated and we're seeing that more
commonly now with omicron your risk of
developing long covid is considerably
lower um
you know much more
50 at least but considerably lower
so that's good news and that
goes back to delta as well and the
number of people who truly have
long coveted symptoms that persist is
probably a less than initially thought
so the data from the uk looks at
probably five to ten percent of people
and that's pre-omicron so we're still
trying to figure out as you know uh omar
khan really burst onto the world stage
less than
12 weeks ago so um trill still trying to
understand it one thing that is clear is
that there are a variety of different
symptoms that have been consistently
associated with people having long covet
and it reminds us that this is a virus
that affects more than the respiratory
symptoms uh respiratory system it has
effects on our
our blood vessels and our blood system
on our heart
and on a neurological system so people
are
as you mentioned and talking about brain
fog but things like
having loss of taste and smell that can
last for quite a long time
and other things that can be more
debilitating so we are still learning a
lot about this
and it doesn't mean that if you're
feeling really unwell in that period of
time
there aren't things you can do and what
i would encourage you to do if you have
a family physician talk to their family
physician
there's a the race line the support line
that the family physician can call to
get advice on things that we know can
help people
get through those symptoms even
before
three months
we know that things like getting rest
those basics that help get help us get
over infections in the first place but
making sure nutrition and and getting
rest and and exercised in a managed way
are things that can help a lot too and
that sounds like motherhood things but
those are very important things for
helping
recover from viral infections
lisa do you have a follow-up
i do regarding the rapid tests and
schools sort of two-fold question um
well i i think a lot of parents were
under the presumption that their child
like each child was going to get a 5
test kit and so there's some frustration
with that and i think when people see
7.4 million sitting in the inventory
wondering why can't they all just go out
now
and also a question was asked
if schools are not vectors of
transmission which have been told all
along why are schools being focused on
to get these rapid tests
well i'll start and i'll turn it over to
the minister but you know if we we talk
about seven million tests and
this is one of my frustrations my pet
peeves
they they're they're in in they're not
seven million individual test kits of
five they're um so divide by five to to
think about how many test kits there are
there and um
initially
the tests that we were distributing
through schools were ones that we had
broken down from kits of 25 or 35 into
three or sometimes single kits so i know
some of those have gone out through
schools but the new ones that have come
in that were started to be distributed
last week come in a box and there's five
tests in the box with the the reagents
and each child uh in a family so if you
have three children you will get each
child would get one of those boxes of
five so that's how we're going to be
moving forward with it
yeah so we know that schools themselves
are not amplifiers but we know that all
of those activities
that kids in school can have covet and
so what the purpose of the rapid antigen
test and this is something the at-home
tests in particular this is something
that we've been looking at for several
months
expecting that we would get more in
finally
so it's not um
it's to help manage you at home so if
you're at home and you do you get up in
the morning and your child has symptoms
it's a tool that can help you determine
whether your child should go into school
today or not so it's for the future for
helping us manage and self-manage and
look after ourselves if we you know if
our child is sick this morning or if
we're
we get a test and we're not feeling well
you can make those decisions about
whether you're going to go visit
an elderly person or whether you need to
stay away from your grandparents for a
couple of days
so it's to help you
make those decisions based on what's
happening for you so
you know i think about it as we often in
in medicine we'll do the test and say if
you don't hear from us then everything's
fine well this is the other way around
you have the test you use them um and if
you if they're positive and you have
concerns then let us know in the health
care system so i think it is a tool that
um is it's not going to solve all our
problems but it is something that people
can use to help them make decisions and
it will help us through this next few
weeks and months but it is something a
tool that we hope will be able to help
us
as we transition through this pandemic
phase
and going forward
uh and as you can see because we've been
reporting on this every week we get a
new rapid antigen test in from the
federal government and we distribute
them we started with the priorities that
we had that we laid out on december 21st
which is to support testing centers
support healthcare workers support
long-term care and assisted living in
rural and remote and indigenous
communities 2k to 12 education to
post-secondary education to child care
and these were our priorities and to
support congregate living and
in different places and those
all of those
areas that we prioritize have now
received sufficient rapid tests to take
them into the future and they'll
continue to be
topped up we now have more tests
available we're making them
available
to students in that system which i think
will be
of assistance to parents and to those
most vulnerable those over 70 and we're
going to move our way through and really
the thing that
will decide how quickly we move through
age groups it will be how quickly we get
rapid tests in so we moved a very
significant number of rapid tests to
schools last week we've started the
process of going through community
pharmacy and
and so you'll see you see
the results of that as we get more in
we'll distribute more out and we'll be
able to drop the age of
where people be accessible so a lot of
people have had access to rapid tests in
the next
in the coming weeks and that will
continue to be the case as they become
available
next question comes from rob monroe info
news hi um thank you for this um dr
henry in looking at the numbers of cases
and hospitalizations and such interior
seems to be declining a bit slower than
the rest of the province i know you've
said in the past that omicron came to
the interior later than the lower
mainland is this just a factor of it's
taking longer to
work its way through or are there other
factors here
i think yeah there's a couple of
different factors
one is it it
they were still dealing with quite a lot
of delta and it was a bit later that we
saw the omicron surge
but it also reflects the fact that in in
a number of communities in the interior
and we're seeing this in the north as
well there's lower rates of vaccination
so the the virus has
much more opportunity to infect more
people um and we're seeing that
reflected in the numbers that we're
seeing in the interior and and in
hospitalization so it has meant
that the peak has been delayed and also
um
going down more slowly and
the proportion of people in hospital is
a little bit higher but we are seeing
we've seen turning the corner the other
thing that we we're also watching is
what proportion of cases are the
the ba 0.2
we are seeing a little bit of an
increase in that it is more infectious
it doesn't seem to cause more severe
illness
but again more infectious in people
particularly who haven't had their
booster dose who aren't vaccinated and
so that's
that's important too as one of the
drivers in some communities
rob do you have a follow-up
oh yes i do i just don't know too
whether it is a concern without further
loosening their regulations
and they tend to come to the okanagan
and
do we have any indication that they're
bringing that here and what are you
doing to try to get that vaccination
rate up in the interior
yeah i know interior health is doing
lots to try and encourage it and
provide information and it really is
going back to those basics
you know
ensuring that people have the
information they need to be confident in
the vaccine that it's accessible and
convenient for them and and to get over
that sense of complacency and i think
we've seen that a little bit with
omicron that there's this uh narrative
that it is a mild disease and it is a
mild disease in people who have that
immune protection uh for the most part
not in everybody but for people who have
vaccinations particularly if you have
two doses of vaccine on board then for
most people it has been a relatively
mild experience it doesn't mean that
it's the same for everybody and we see
that in in people who have died and we
see that it is older people even with
vaccination who are still most at risk
so we need to take those measures to
protect them i would also say that you
know for everybody in the interior who's
not yet
availed themselves of vaccine we now
have a new option for you the nova fax
and i know
there's a lot of concerns in some
communities there was concerns about
the mrna vaccines and i think this is a
very effective alternative for you
and i encourage you to call the the call
center the um 1-833-838-2323
and put your name on the list to get
your vaccine as soon as possible and yes
we do see there's quite a lot of people
moving back and forth between alberta
and and parts of the interior and the
north
what we need to say is you know when
you're here we expect you to do the
things that we're all doing to protect
each other and our communities here in
vc so
that's following the guidelines that we
have in place making sure that you do
avail yourself of the opportunities to
get protection through vaccination
next question goes to cole skizzler
black press
colt shitless thank you for taking my
question
it's not long covered
so to access the post covid 19 recovery
clinic people need to have a positive
coven 19 swap or a positive serology
test
during the peak of our omicron wave
testing capacity was limited here in the
province so for people who were unable
to access a test because of lack of
supply who may have got omicron it may
now have long covered what what supports
are available for those people yeah so
there is a serology test as you
mentioned that can tell whether you've
had
an infection with covid so that's one of
the things that the clinic can do so
again it's talk to your your family
doctor if you have one you can call
8-1-1 to get advice about how to do that
but talk to your clinician make sure you
can get
that the signs and symptoms are assessed
your physicians and nurse practitioners
can get
direct access to clinicians who are
working in those clinics we only
you know they're not available in every
community but they are designed to be a
hub and spoke so they can support your
family physician in your community in
supporting you as well and part of that
assessment
if you've not had a test and you have
had covet-like symptoms is to get a
serology test that will help understand
if you were infected or not and yes you
can tell the difference between
some of the immune markers from
vaccination versus
from infection so that's
that is available and the clinicians in
the uh the post-vaccination or the
postcovid recovery clinics
can provide advice on how to get those
tests if they're if they're indicated
thank you cole schizler do you have a
follow-up
yes thank you um
does bc recognize long covered as a
disability
that's a very good question
so it's not
my role our role to recognize a
disability it depends on the symptoms
that somebody has so and it would depend
on the circumstances that they have so
if somebody need for work for example um
it would uh go through things like
work safe bc assessments and to
determine if it was a work related
disability so yes some people who have
long cobid
do have disabilities but it's
specific to the individual and it
depends on what signs and symptoms they
have and how it affects them so that's a
discussion that's between an individual
and their clinician about how
the illness is affecting them
individually
we have time for one more question today
we'll go to karen larson cbc
oh hi thanks very much i would like
answers in english and french if you
could please so dr henry how do you
explain what appears to be a relatively
low rate of vaccination for five to 11
year olds
yeah well um this is something actually
we had a long conversation about that
with colleagues across the
uh across the
the country as well as some
international experts just today um you
know this is something that we're seeing
uh across the board
um
if we look at we're at about 55 percent
here in bc and that's about the same as
ontario quebec and uh most of provinces
across the country the exception of
newfoundland and labrador where they
have overall much higher immunization
rates
it is also aligned with the polling they
early on before vaccine was available we
asked parents about intentions to
vaccinate younger children so i think
there's some
and it's it's what we heard we heard
that about 50 of parents were going to
sign up right away and then there was a
proportion of people 20 to 30 percent
who wanted to understand more and wait
until they saw more information more
data about the vaccine
we now know quite a lot more about how
covit is affecting that younger age
group and about the safety of the
vaccines how well they're working so
we are all at a point now where we need
to look at okay what do we do to provide
that information that parents are
looking for and to support them and
getting children vaccinated so
again i think it is important we have
seen and we've seen in our data here in
bc a higher number now of younger
children
because it's been omicron has been
transmitting so
widely we're seeing more children need
hospital care thankfully it's still
quite low
in terms of rates but it does mean that
the more children who are affected the
more children will have severe illness
and end up in hospital either from
exacerbation of a asthma or other
illnesses or from covet itself so
it is important to protect children and
now we have a lot of information about
how well these vaccines work and how
safe they are
it's also i believe really important for
helping to get us through these
trying times for children particularly
in schools to make it easier for them
to participate fully in activities and
not worry that they're bringing it home
to family members who may be more
vulnerable so there's a whole lot of
reasons why why it is important to
continue
to
provide the information that's needed
and for children to be vaccinated
and i really encourage parents talk to
your pediatrician talk to your
pharmacist talk to your public health
nurse in your community because we have
lots more information now that really
support how safe these vaccines are how
well they work and the impacts that
covet has had on younger people because
we do need to get those immunization
rates up i think it's going to be really
important for getting us through this
transition phase but also for protecting
young children for what comes next
i think and we'll share this with you
karen which you may be interested in and
with reporters
if you go from the age of 17 down
and under 18 every time you go down one
year
each cohort the number of uh
of people youth or children vaccinated
gets less and less so 17 and 16 year
olds are actually vaccinated above the
parental average of vaccination then it
declines every every individual year
cohort down to age five and so and the
other thing we see in the numbers is
well there isn't a great deal of
difference between
adults over 70 in different parts and
different living in different health
authority regions in the province
there is a significant difference
between
children 5 and 11 as by health authority
with the highest levels of vaccination
for children five to eleven being in
vancouver coastal health above uh the
seventy percent mark so uh that's those
are the basic informations for uh
[Music]
[Music]
karen do you have a follow-up
yes i do and english and french again if
you could please uh minister dicks is
there anything the province could have
done differently than to try and
increase those numbers of the five to 11
year olds or to convince parents to
vaccinate their children and should we
expect a different strategy
yeah so
you know we had a very intentional
strategy based on the information that
we received from parents and from
guardians and from
community members about
about what they were looking for in
vaccinating children so we have done it
in a whole variety of settings but we
really have focused the things that we
heard that were most important were
having immunizers who were used to
dealing with children and being with
children and having
clinics that were designed to make it an
experience that was as least dramatic as
possible for children so we've done that
and you see as we're transitioning
to much of the mass clinics being scaled
back we're focusing on having those
important experiences where you can
bring your child even if they have
concerns even if they're
you're worried that they're going to
scream or be upset or be concerned
because we know that the people there at
those clinics know how to how to make
this an experience that's uh positive
for children and to make sure that that
that they are vaccinated in a way that
supports them
that was the number one most important
thing so we have been focusing on that
having said that in different
communities we have tried and worked on
many different aspects of of the the
supporting families um making sure it's
in a place where they feel comfortable
in a language that they feel comfortable
the information is in a format that
resonates and that
answers the questions that that parents
have so there's a lot that we've done
and
we will continue uh to follow along um
with that strategy uh um you know a
parent a family a community at a time to
make sure that we're providing those
opportunities for all young people to
get vaccinated and i mentioned we were
on this uh
this call you know this is something
that we're seeing in many communities
around the world
and that it is really about addressing
what i keep calling the the three c's so
you know complacency the the sense that
children aren't at risk
um convenience making it easy for
parents making it in a language that
they understand in a setting that they
feel comfortable all of those things are
really really important and confidence
in the vaccine and as we have more and
more young children vaccinated and we've
seen the effects that covet is having
particularly omicron over the last few
weeks we have more and more information
to build confidence and to share with
parents so we will continue to really
focus on
addressing those needs for families and
for parents and for children
and uh as you know 93.5 percent of
adults
over 18 have received their first oscova
19 vaccination over 91 percent have
received their second dose
of those eligible well over
60 percent of adults have received their
booster doses so i think there's a
strong understanding of the need for
vaccination we talked to people prior to
the approval of the pediatric
vaccination from five to eleven that
many parents told us that they wanted to
wait a while well
two hundred thousand children now have
uh or just under two hundred thousand
children have received their uh
specially designed uh pediatric vaccine
and it's proven to be effective it's
proven to be safe and i think this is a
moment we're going to continue to see
parents bring their children to be
vaccinated so we're
we're continuing to
to grind those numbers up slowly and i
expect we'll continue to do so and that
will succeed in it i think one of the
differences between the availability of
vaccines for adults
and the availability for children it was
a little different you'll recall that we
got access to the vaccines
in on december 13th or so of 2020 for
adults but because of supply it was
quite a bit of time before most adults
had access to them we focused on
long-term care and other things so
people had time with it whereas with the
pediatric vaccines basically we had
sufficient vaccine in uh
immediately so that period which some
people took to wait and consider was not
available and so we're going to we
believe strongly believe that the
evidence is so strong that it makes
children safer that it makes their
families safer that that it will make
everywhere around them safer that we're
going to continue to see those numbers
go up there are regional differences
though and so we have to continue to
provide information you saw that fraser
health
put out an information bulletin today
about
some new places where the pediatric
vaccine will be available and i what i
would say is and what will continue
there's a real focus of public health on
ensuring that
that the people doing the vaccinations
have lots of experience with children
and the experience that that i've heard
from parents is how positive it has been
in our vaccination clinic and that has
everything to do with the extraordinary
work done by public health nurses and
doctors and others
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much see you next week
you